in this video we're going to talk about
the ratio of similar figures okay so
let's go through some examples and we'll
do a problem as you would like to see it
on the act so first of all when you're
talking about the ratio of similar
figures what exactly does that mean well
first of all similar figures means that
they're the same
shape okay but not necessarily the same
size so there's a scale factor that
relates
you know how much larger how much
smaller you know one figure is in
relation to the other figure and the way
that you can find that scale factor is
let's say you were going from figure a
to figure b
what you would want to do to find that
scale factor is you take the new length
divided by the old length so i'm going
from a to b you can see the length is
five the old length was three so the
scale factor is going to be five thirds
now if i was going the other direction
from b to a then the scale factor would
be three-fifths you know you're on the
right track because if the scale factor
is greater than one it should be getting
larger right if the scale factor is
between zero and one like a three-fifths
for example that's less than one it's
getting smaller
okay now if you wanted to compare let's
say the ratio of the perimeter say you
were just looking at one of these faces
here and you wanted to compare like
what's the ratio of the perimeter of
this face to the perimeter of this face
what you would do is you would look at
the scale factor
perimeter is the same thing as length if
you were to stretch out you know
perimeter it's really just length just
like the scale factor is comparing these
two lengths so the ratio of the
perimeters would be the same as the
scale factor five thirds
but if you're comparing the area of this
face to the area of this face
area is two dimensional it's length
times width or base times height so what
you're going to do is you're going to
take that scale factor in this case 5 3
and you're going to square it so that's
25 9 you want to square the numerator
and the denominator and if you're doing
volume volume is length times width
times height so that's three dimensional
you want to take that scale factor five
thirds and you want to cube it so now
the ratio of the volumes would be 125
over 27. so let's just do an example
here to show you how this works say you
have these two
pentagonal prisms here and the volume of
this little one is 10 cubic units and we
want to find the volume of this larger
one and they tell us that the scale
factor is times two okay so everything's
being doubled
so what we would do then is we'd say
well if it's volume it's going to
actually be 2 cubed the scale factor
cube it's going to actually be 8 times
larger so 10 times 8 this volume is
actually going to be 80 cubic units okay
some students will make the mistake of
just saying oh it's 20 it's double but
it's actually the length is double the
width is double the height is doubled so
it's two times two times two it's
actually eight times larger and there
you go so let's go through this example
here
try this on your own and we can go
through it together so first of all
if a nine inch diameter personal pizza
costs eight dollars
and an extra large pizza is 18 inch
diameter if the price is proportional to
the area the pizza covers okay so when
it's laying on the cardboard there right
how much should the extra large pizza
cost okay assuming that it's
proportional to the area
okay so what you would do here is you
let's just draw a picture that always
helps so if it's a diameter is 9 that
means the radius is 4.5 and if this
larger extra large pizza has a diameter
of 18 that means its radius is 9. so you
can see the scale factor is
one to two or you can say this one is
two times larger right so if it's two
times larger the area okay is going to
be the scale factor squared it's going
to be two squared so this is actually
going to cover four times
the area like you could actually take
and put
four of these personal size pizzas
okay
inside of this larger pizza some of
these overlapping regions we could fill
in these little gaps here right
okay so let's see so basically if it's
eight dollars for the small one times
four since it's proportional it should
be thirty two dollars for the extra
large that would be your answer now in
real life they usually give you a
discount when you buy in bulk so it
might only be like twenty dollars or
something like that but uh that's how
you would do this type of problem so
review the ratio
of the scale factor the perimeters the
areas and the volumes and just be
familiar with that for the ect i'll see
in the next lesson